Hey Dude let's come to you first we just
all need to lighten up a bit don't we
well that would be true if it wasn't for
the case that for the last several years
we've been bombarded by the media and
politicians and insisting that we've
gotta watch your language you know we
mustn't use his speech we mustn't use
violent language and then up pops Joe
Brown at the BBC suggesting it might be
a hoot if someone got some battery acid
in their face that's okay is it no it's
not it's a pigment double standard and
that's really Jonathan might be for this
I believe in his free speech I believe
people comedians should be allowed to
say what they want but this was
broadcast in the BBC and the BBC has a
very clear hypocritical double standard
here insofar as it allows Joe Brown to
do this but not that long ago it
dismissed Danny maker Danny Baker for
making someone perhaps offensive but not
allowed or distasteful visual joke so
you know you gotta ask yourself Jonathan
Curtis the where's the consistency here
lately see David wasn't the whole point
of this radio show that it's poking fun
at exactly what you're talking about
this toxic debate that has happened over
brexit this programme the whole point of
it is to poke fun at that well the thing
is the BBC in particular is very keen to
lecture people from other political
perspectives and and you know when it
comes to be one of their own unless face
if Joe Brown has been on the BBC for a
very long time that seems to have a
double standard and another quick point
if I may say it was Joe Brandt who in a
pre-ind some years gone past God Carol
Thatcher sacked from a BBC programme
over a comment that she heard Carol
Thatcher say so you know if it's all
about free speech then jew-jew bran is
an absolute hypocrite and we shouldn't
make excuses for her and Nigel Faraj is
absolutely right to demand that she'll
be investigated for incitement because
that's frankly what it is Wow so Tom the
BBC accused of double standards Joe
Brown accused of being a hypocrites
where do you stand now I find it
extraordinary in this day and age that
we're debating this right there are two
things you need to look at context and
intent that was the first time I'd
actually heard the clip and the context
is there plain as day because you can
hear people laughing at it right it is a
comedian telling a joke on a comedy
program so that's the context it is
clearly a joke within that context
intent do we honestly think that Joe
Brown wants us to throw acid on
politicians faces if you actually
believe that you arm it willfully in my
opinion misunderstanding what what a
joke is so I I think the intent there
was to have a laugh
comedians jobs a retort car in comedian
once said that it's a comedian's job to
find where the line that you shouldn't
cross is and then gently step over it I
think we're in a whit's heading into
this rather puritanical age where most
comedians these days feel that they have
to stay a couple of metres behind that
line comedy is about hyperbole irony I'm
shocked sometimes but I think this is a
dangerous president when the Prime
Minister is getting involved having a
pop at the BBC for telling jokes on a
comedy programme I find it absolutely
bizarre it wasn't clearly an incitement
of hatred I wonder whether Nigel Faraj
is kind of trolling us a little bit and
having a pop really at the the snow
flake left because it's normally quite
often the left that are going you know
we need to watch ourselves with our
language more so than the right but I'm
a big believer in free speech generally
but certainly within this particular
context it was clearly a joke if you
didn't like it switch off and don't
watch Joe Brand again so simple as that
if I can just ask him a question Tom
tell me this if somebody had battery
acid thrown in their face today would
that be funny no it wouldn't be funny of
course it wouldn't be funny because that
would be someone causing physical harm
it wouldn't be the same as someone
telling a joke if someone threw battery
acid in someone's face because they
heard that joke on Radio 4 I presume
then that person has clear mental health
issues in his unable to understand the
context and intent of a joke Joe Brown
would have absolute would not be
culpable at all if someone went out
today and started throwing asset of
people that person is the criminal that
person is responsible for their actions
not Joe brand and yet by the same token
we've had in the past 12 months a couple
of quite quite famous cases we had a
Scottish comedian called Mark Meacham
they always operated it under the name
kind Don killer who taught his pug to
make Nazi salutes on the basis of that
he was prosecuted by the police he was
fined
yeah medium and heavily against him I
know that I can't a particular [ __ ] just
finished we for the you kept candidate
in the form of Carl Benjamin ruled
mercilessly by the media over a joke
that he made three years ago so a manic
in first where's the consistency okay
for a brand not okay for Carl Benjamin
nor Oh care for Morgan David were like
well I would say this if I may that that
I I've defended Marcus mention quite
publicly before and he was prosecuted
for what is clearly a joke and the the
judge in that particular case that said
that context and intent wasn't relevant
I don't agree with those two people's
politics in any way shape or form and I
do think with the Carl Benjamin case he
was running for office and therefore you
should hire hold yourself to a higher
standard than a comedian is and so yes
there is hypocrisy and double standards
but I do think in this case as in with
most of these cases I'm sorry it was a
joke and if you were offended and just
because you're offended doesn't mean
you're right you know if you're
genuinely offended about it like I say
switch off David
David if we stop comedians pushing the
boundaries if we stop them doing that
then then what next what sort of society
did we do we become we become a
humorless drama society Jonathan and not
guard I would agree with Tom my beef and
this one if you like it is in particular
regard to the BBC the BBC that doesn't
think it's appropriate for example to
play reruns of aliens half hot mum from
the 1980s
no no that's not suitable for the BBC
but gags about acid attacks in the face
that's Rep Rowley hilarious and John Tom
mentioned the fact that the audience
harmed with laughter again mikrotik is
not just with Joel brand it's with the
BBC and in fact those who constitute BBC
audiences I'm all for any humour Tom the
anterior the better in my view but I'm
also against two-faced hypocrisy and
it's two-faced Apocrypha that we see
manifest with the BBC over this
particular situation David a it ain't
half hot mum was was was blatantly
racist wasn't it and there was no
apology for that it was racist simple as
that when Joe Brown made her comment she
followed it up by saying I'm not going
to do it it's purely a fantasy but
milkshakes are pathetic I'm sorry she
was making it very clear to the audience
that what she was saying was a joke
what's pathetic tom is you choosing to
pass judgment and something that
millions of people during the 1980s find
extremely hilarious and I'm sure the
laughter was even greater than Joel
brands acid in your face joke if I may
you know I think attitudes do change and
and sometimes they change too quickly
for everyone to keep up and what was
acceptable 10 20 years ago is different
to what was acceptable today and you
know things are changing and some call
it progress some don't but yes I mean it
would be difficult to get away with
showing a tan ain't half hot mum without
quite a few trigger war things all over
it
but I think you know humor things like
that above sorry good we may be an area
of commonality we Harvey don't know
we've become a weak society because
people are being
actually trained to trigger and and to
go and hide because they're exposed to
something they don't like don't get me
wrong
show brand she can make as many jokes as
she wants on whatever topics that she
wants that's absolutely fine by me but
the BBC Tom has a direct responsibility
not least in the fact that it takes 3.8
billion a year of our taxes the fund the
humor of Joe brand and others